bonjour Monsieur le Secrétaire général
de la merè merci de votre présence et
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
convocation pour cette audition avant de
de vous soumettre à l'obligation de
prestation de serment qui est devant une
commission d'enquête je vous propose de
présenter les personnes qui vous
accompagnent
monsieur Monsieur Benoît Piguet qui est
mon chef de cabinet et Madame Caroline
NAF qui est le chargé de mission
douane du
SGM bienvenue à eux alors du coup je je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévu aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et
donc je vais inviter chacune et chacun
d'entre vous de ceux qui prendront la
parole à prêter serement de dire toute
la vérité rien que la vérité à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure je le
jure je le
jure je le jure merci merci ce que je
vous propose peut-être pour euh euh le
déroulement de cette audition c'est que
on vous laisse dérouler un propos
liminire et puis on interviendra ensuite
en question-réponse très bien monsieurle
vousid merci beaucoup
alors peut-être vous précisez un peu ce
qu'est le hgmr parce que cette ce petit
organisme n'est pas forcément très très
connu et vous dire quel est notre rôle
en matière de lutte contre les trafics
de drogues donc le hgmr a été créé par
un décret de
1995 hein est rattaché directement à la
première ministre et j'exerce pour son
compte c'est sa compétence propre ce
qu'on appelle l'action de l'État en mer
alors l'action de en mer est défini par
une liste de 45 missions qui que je veux
pas vous vous vous énumérer mais qui
vont de la protection de l'environnement
puisque le SG mer a été
créé à partir des grandes catastrophes
maritimes des années 70 des grandes
pollutions donc c'est son métier de
départ historiquement et puis bien
évidemment tout ce qui est la police de
la mer dans toutes ces
variantes en tant que secrétaire général
de la mer j'ai donc l'autorité sur les
préfets maritimes en métropole et les
délégués de l'action de l'État en mer en
outre mer pour l'exercice de ces
compétences les préfets maritimes je je
vous le rappelle aussi rapidement en
métropole sur chacune des trois façades
manchem du Nord Atlantique et
Méditerranée sont à la fois des
autorités civiles de police et en même
temps des chefs militaires donc c'est
une c'est une création ancienne he
puisque ça remonte au consulat comme
toute une série de choses et donc on a
gardé cette
spécificité c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont à la
fois cette capacité d'intervenir sur les
sujets que j'évoqué rapidement de police
de la mer mais
également de par leurs compétences marin
national ils ont la
possibilité de de de fongibiliser si
vous me éit l'expression l'ensemble des
moyens puisque ce qui fait l'action de
l'État en mer c'est la fonction
garde-côte et cette fonction garde-côte
comme son nom l'indique est une fonction
il n'y a pas un corps de garde-côte
comme nos amis américains mais concours
à la fonction garde-côte principalement
la Marine nationale mais également les
douanes et finalement tous les services
de l'État qui mettent des embarcations à
l'eau lors qu'un semiriigide par exemple
est mis à l'eau par la gendarmerie
nationale ou la police de de l'air et
des frontières il relève de cette
autorité de la fonction garde-côte pour
gérer cette fonction il y a une
comitologie qui qui existe qui permet de
se coordonner avec l'ensemble des
administrations mais l'opérationnelle
est géré sur le terrain en l'occurrence
qu' n'en est pas un puisqu'il s'agit de
la mer par les préfets maritimes et les
préfets en en outreem les préfets de
zone en outrem si vous voulez par par
exemple aux Antilles le délégué de
l'action de l'État en mer c'est le
préfet de Martinique en tant qu'il est
préfet de zone
terrestre dans dans dans à la Réunion
Mayotte c'est le préfet de la Réunion
même si il y a une délégation pour le
préfet de maotte parce que c'est
tellement loin que le préfet de la
Réunion ne peut pas
traiter tout seul les sujets
maritimes à Mayotte voilà ça ça
fonctionne de cette façonlà et donc ce
sont eux sur le terrain qui gèent
l'opérationnel du dispositif alors pour
les prémars c'est assez simple
puisqu'ils ont l'ensemble des manettes
hein et le domaine de compétence d'un
prémar quand je dis les façades par
exemple la compétence du prémar
Atlantique elle va de la limite des
Antilles jusque au golfe de Guinée même
en DEA donc ce sont des zones
extrêmement vaste sur lesquels nous
appliquons l'ensemble de ces règles qui
sont en fait organisé par toute une
série de traités internationaux et qui
nous permettent s'agissant du sujet qui
vous préoccupe de lutter contre la
drogue je suis l'ensemble de cette
activité au travers d'un centre
opérationnel de la fonction garde-côte
qui me permet de faire des des des
synthèses et un suivi à la première
ministre centre opérationnel la fonction
garde-côte qui est situé à Ballard
auprès de l'état-major de la marine en
terme géographique mais qui est composé
de chacune qui est armée par chacune des
composantes que j'ai décrite rapidement
que j'ai décrit rapidement c'est-à-dire
marine douane
euh et euh
gendarmerie bien sûr affaires maritimes
et qui permettent ce suivi des
opérations voilà j'insiste là-dessus
c'est-à-dire que c'est véritablement un
dispositif
déconcentré je suis bien sûr tenu au
courant de l'ensemble des opérations
mais je ne dirige pas des saisis dans le
Golfe de Guinée ça serait complètement
surréaliste hein c'est véritablement
géré au niveau opérationnel par les
prémars ou par les délégués de l'action
de l'État en mer voilà bien sûr nous
avons donc ce ce ce travail de lutte
contre la drogue en mer puisque ma
compétence s'arrête sur le rivage petite
exception quand même mais qui est dû au
aux circonstances le premier la première
ministre m'a demandé de
suivre et de mieux coordonner les la
lutte contre la drogue dans le domaine
portuaire et au travers d'une commission
qui s'appelle la commission
interministérielle de sûreté portuaire
la
sismap et dans laquelle nous examinons
un certain nombre de dispositifs pour
justement améliorer notre notre
efficacité en matière de de lutte contre
la toxicomanie dans les pororts alors
pourquoi dans les Pors parce que la
cocaïne et surtout parce que la première
ministre a voulu que véritablement nous
mettions un coup d'arrêt enfin un coup
d'arrêt que nous puissions au moins
lutter efficacement contre le trafic
dans portuire parce que vous le savez
une grande partie de la cocaïne arrive
malheureusement dans les ports d'Europe
du Nord qui ont rehaussé leur dispositif
de protection et il fallait que nous
puissions rehausser le nôtre or le
système portuaire en terme de suivi
étatique est assez compliqué puisqu'il y
a à la fois un préfet qui est chargé du
du du suivi de la sûreté que ce sont les
c'est le ministère des transport au
travers de la DGITM qui a la compétence
en matière de suivi de enfin de tutelle
en matière de suivi des différentes
autorités portuaires quand il s'agit des
grands ports de l'État bien évidemment
je parle pas des ports décentralisés et
nous avons d'autres acteurs dont je
parlais tout à l'heure les douanes
notamment qui interviennent sur le
dispositif portuire don la donc la
nécessité d'une coordination
interministérielle au travers de cette
sismap euh pour marquer l'intérêt que
que la première ministre porte à ces
sujetsl elle a demandé à son directeur
de cabinet de présider cette sismap ce
qui donne quand même une portée un peu
supérieure au dispositif de comitologie
et nous avons pris un certain nombre de
décisions que nous allons mettre en
œuvre sur la sûreté dans les ports la
première c'est
de faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
criblages soit désormais traité par le
snéas le criblage c'est le criblage de
toute personne rentrant dans un grand
port maritime on doit avoir bien sûr une
carte d'accès la carte d'accès est
délivrée après un criblage sur les
différents fichiers pour savoir si la
personne est honorablement enfin n'est
pas à l'inverse malheureusement connu et
donc ce qui ce qui ne permettrait pas de
délivrer l' l'habilitation mais en
criblant par l'intermédiaire du sneas
vous avez cet organisme qui est placé
auprès du ministère de l'intérieur on
peut cribler au travers des fichiers de
souverineté ce qui euh par rapport à des
menaces de haute intensité est quand
même préférable et ce dispositif nous
l'avons préparé il nécessite une
modification des textes et il se
déploiera progressivement à partir du
début de l'année 2024 je pourrais
revenir sur le le dispositif il est
assez complexe parce qu'il nous amène à
à à le faire à la fois dans les zones
portuaires réservées mais dans ce qu'on
appelle également les installations
portuaires bon tout ça est un dispositif
un peu complexe mais retenez que
l'objectif est d'arriver à un criblage
beaucoup plus efficace sur les accès
permanents dans les zones portuaires ça
n'est pas le le seul le seul objectif
que nous poursuivons dans dans le
pororttoire la douane va déployer à
partir de du milieu de l'année 2024 là
le marché est en train d'être est en est
pas encore attribué mais est en train
d'être mis en œuvre toute une série de
scanners c'est-à-dire qui permettront de
scanner les containers parce qu'une des
difficultés que nous avons c'est que
très peu de containers sont scannés vous
savez qu'il y a on scanne à peu près 2 %
des containers au plan mondial hein tout
simplement parce queil y en a
énormément et donc le le le le la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue sera beaucoup
plus efficace en scannant les les les
les les containers bon là aussi ça pose
quelques petites difficultés techniques
mais nous allons à partir de la mi- 2024
arriver dans les grands ports maritimes
à disposer d'un d'un dispositif un peu
plus un peu plus efficace voilà je vous
cite ces deux mesure il y en a plusieurs
autres en matière dans dans le
dispositif portuaire mais c'est un peu
une exception à ma compétence
strictement maritime j'ai mis un pied
dans les ports au travers de ce travail
de coordination qui m'a été confié sinon
mon rôle s'arrête
véritablement lorsque on passe sur terre
et là ce sont les préfets terrestres
hein qui prennent la main dans en
matière de lutte contre la drogue même
si la coordination dans les ports se
fait avec eux voilà la petite
présentation je pouvais vous faire
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur notre rapporteur Étienne
blanc ouvre les question très bien merci
Monsieur le Secrétaire général vous avez
mentionné l'intervention de plusieurs
services de l'État comment jugez-vous la
coordination entre ces différents serv
service est-ce que vous avez
diagnostiqué des points faibles et
est-ce qu'éventuellement vous pourriez
nous dire quelques pistes pour y
remédier si si ils existent et puis une
deuxième question on surveille un
domaine maritime qui est très très vaste
et nous le faisons avec les différents
pays côtiers est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez nous dire où vous pouvez pointer
un certain nombre de pays qui sont
défaillants peut-être parce qu' n'ont
pas les moyens peut-être aussi parce
qu'ils n'ont pas la volonté politique
peut peut-être aussi parce qu' ils ne
s'inscrivent pas dans une coopération
internationale est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire contenu de l'importance de
Cees trafic de drogue sur l'espace
maritime s'il y a un certain nombre de
points faibles connus
oui monsieur le rapporteur il y a il y a
beaucoup de de points faibles
identifiés parce qu'en matière maritime
certes il y a
des conventions internationales des
traités qui régissent le droit de la mer
mais le droit de la mer connaît toujours
un certain nombre
d'interstices dans lequel se glissent
les les les trafiquants bon je vais vous
en donner un récent qu'on a qu'on a
constaté là après tout qui concerne un
dispositif qui concerne le dispositif
européen c'est le problème du pavillon
hein le le le le droit de la mer
prévoit que lorsque nous AR raisonnons
au titre de l'action de l'État en mer
avec des navires français un bâtiment
suspect nous devons et c'est bien
naturel saisir le l'État du pavillon
d'une demande de visite à bord pour
justement avoir confirmation que les
doutes que nous avons que le
renseignement qui a été émis est bien
confirmé par exemple par la présence de
drogue donc tous les États se doivent
d'avoir un centre qui permet met un
centre d'appel qui permet de donner une
réponse extrêmement rapide pour
autoriser à visiter parce que quand vous
êtes en mer et que vous êtes à côté d'un
navire vous pouvez pas attendre 15 jours
la réponse donc faut que ça soit assez
rapide et nous avons remarqué que des
États qui permettent des facilité
fiscale sur
l'immatriculation du coup se retrouve
avec beaucoup de pavillons ne sont pas
toujours en
mesure de répondre dans les délais c'est
par exemple le cas de nos amis polonais
hein qui immatriculle beaucoup de navir
parce que semble-t-il il y a des
facilités mais qui ne se sont pas dotés
d'un dispositif extrêmement pertinent et
qui malheureusement dans bien des cas ne
répondent pas hein ce qui est un
véritable sujet pour justement avoir ces
suites enfin c'est un petit exemple
parmi tous les exemples que que que nous
avons sur les interstices qui se créent
dans le dispositif du droit de la mère
en matière de drogue mais c'est
principalement ce genre de chos sachant
que N sommes soumis quand même à des
dispositifs juridiques qui peuvent enfin
nous sommes soumis nous avons des
dispositifs juridiques qui peuvent
peut-être un peu vous étonner le plus
efficace pour nous étant celui dit de la
dissociation qui est permis par la loi
française c'est-à-dire
que en accord avec les parquets lorsque
nous sommes vraiment très très loin de
nos bases c'est ce qui se passe par
exemple dans le Golfe de Guinée euh nous
saisissons la cargaison sans
forcément déférer devant les
juges les personnes sur le bateau hein
de manière à rendre le moyen
opérationnel c'estàdire nous détruisons
la drogue en laissant le bateau
continuer c'est prévu par les textes par
une loi de
95 94 pardon et nous avons donc ce type
de pratique parce que ce qui nous semble
le plus efficace c'est de détruire la
drogue alors évidemment
des renseignements sont pris sur le
navire son équipage et on signale au
pays de destination du moins celui qui
est déclaré par le navire l'arrivée du
navire mais voilà on a ce type de
procédure parce que sinon quand vous
arrêtez enfin quand vous immobiliser un
navire dans le Golfe de Guinée revenir
en France par exemple à Brest voyez le
nombre de jours qu'il faudrait et ça ça
ça ça atténuerait notre action voilà
mais on a on a ce type ce type de de
difficulté alors après les trafiquants
de drogue sont extrêmement imaginatifs
hein on découvre des choses qui chaque
jour nous étonnent un peu plus et donc
il y a forcément d'autres trous dans
notre
dispositifs pas forcément des
défaillances d'État mais on voit bien
que les contrôles au départ d'un certain
nombre de pays ne sont pas aussi
approfondis qu'on pourrait le
souhaiter
la coordination entre les différents
services
français bon bah écoutez en étant chargé
je vais vous dire qu'elle est excellente
tout se passe bien que tout se passe
bien mais je je je pense que je crois
profondément que c'est vrai les les les
les choses se passent bien si vous
voulez en mer il faut une fiabilité du
renseignement c'est le renseignement qui
vous permet de déterminer parce que vous
pouvez toujours aller à l'aveugle et
contrôler un navire à l'aveugle mais euh
même si le trafic maritime est intense
et croisez pas quand même un bateau
toutes les 5 minutes donc contrôler tous
les bateaux comme on peut le faire à
terre contrôler tous les camions lorsque
vous faites un barrage ça n'aurait aucun
sens donc ce qui compte c'est la
fiabilité du renseignement et la
coordination des renseignements entre
les services français au travers
justement euh des préfets maritimes ou
des délégués de l'action de l'État en
mer et notamment c'est le travail fait
par les czdm auprès d'eux c'est-à-dire
les commandants de zone
maritime on arrive à bien coordonner le
renseignement et puis bon il y a des il
y a des outils extrêmement utiles type
mahoc en Europe qui sont assez efficaces
mais c'est ça qui compte c'est le le
renseignement savoir très précisément où
il faut aller bon après
euh il y a des processus de trafic de
drogues sur
[Musique]
lesquels on travaille et notamment sur
les CL clignotement d'AIS vous savez
lais c'est le sur les navires c'est la
balise que que les que les navires ont
qui permettent de les de les repérer les
Aes c'est comme le suivi des avions vous
pouvez y avoir accès en vous pouvez y
avoir accès en source ouverte hein sur
votre Smartphone vous pouvez suivre un
navire et alors celui qui éteint alors
c'est pas la is et séteint de temps en
temps euh pour nous c'est un signal
voilà
euh
un navire qui près des côtes françaises
par exemple éteindrait son
ais au large de la Bretagne et le
remettrait en marche en manch mer du
Nord
euh ça peut être une panne
ou alors ceux qui font des zigzags si
vous voulez le navire qui a toujours son
ais et qui d'un seul coup alors que le
propre des navires c'est d'aller le plus
droit possible pour économiser du
carburant hein qui d'un seul coup se met
à fait des zigzags comme ça bon soit le
capitaine a un peu forcé sur la boisson
soit il y a une autre raison voilà donc
c'est ce genre de choses qui nous
permettent de de de détecter mais en
matière de coordination pour répondre à
votre question monsieur le rapporteur je
pense que le dispositif est assez
pertinent bien sûr on aimerait avoir
tous plus de navir pour faire plus de
contrôle plus de personnel mais enfin
indépendamment de ça je pense que ça
fonctionne assez
efficacement question de notre collègue
mar l Carlotti oui merci Monsieur le
Secrétaire général sur ce que vous avez
dit sur le fait qu'effectivement les
ports du nord de l'Europe qui étaient
très très touché par le trafic se sont
consolidés et que du coup nous vous nous
avez dit combien nous aussi on devait
rehausser nos dispositif vous avez parlé
de criblage c'est très important d'accès
au port donc hein du scan plus
systématique des containers mais je sais
qu'il y a eu d'autres mesures que vous
avez déjà fait et d'autres qui vous
allez envisager je pensais à des mesures
notamment concernant ant les les
douiniers avec à la fois espèce de
davantage de mobilité de formation
semble-t-il voilà moi sur toutes ces
mesures ça m'intéresse que vous nous en
disiez plus ou que vous nous en donniez
les éléments peut-être qu'on aura pas le
temps de le faire aujourd'hui mais vous
avez essentiellement parlé des grands
ports d'État or il se trouve que les
petits ports sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement touchés et fragilisés par
par pareil hein ils ont très bien
compris que peut-être la surveillance
était moins important dans les petits
ports et ils sont énormément touchés
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les petits
ports est-ce que ça relève de votre
compétence ou pas enfin ça je ne sais
pas la chose la la situation ça serait
intéressant que vous m'en disiez plus le
deuxème question c'est vous quelle est
votre la relation que vous pouvez avoir
avec le secteur privé sur les ports
notamment avec les industriels les
dockers les aconniers ou les gens qui
font de la réparation navale voilà
peut-être qu'il y a aussi un travail et
de coopération à avoir avec eux et vous
avez évoqué des choses tout à l'heure
qui je savais même pas que ça existait
notamment le le déchargement au large
des gens qui enfin des bateaux qui qui
jettent la la cam à la mer parce que ils
sont pris ils sentent qu'ils vont être
attrapés et cetera est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous rencontrer ce
genre ce genre de chos dans vos
fonctions
oui madame la sénatrice je vais répondre
d'ailleurs en commençant par la fin oui
ce qu'on appelle le déchargement au
large dans notre jargon c'est le dropof
c'est-à-dire c'est balancé à la mer des
des paquets euh que que les qu'un navire
le navire mer jette sa drogue qui est
empacté de façon étanche éventuellement
avec une balise et un navire fille vient
le récupérer ce qui explique que
quelquefois pour des raisons soit de
temps de mer soit de d'erreur humaines
il rate les paquets et c'est pour ça que
vous trouvez des quelquefois des paquets
de drogue sur les plages de la Manche
euh quand ça se passe dans cette zoneel
les courants emène les les les paquets à
cet endroitlà enfin les les ballots quoi
hein donc on sait que c'est un c'est un
des modes de trafic de drogue le
problème du du trafic de drogue c'est
que enfin de la cocaïne en l'occurrence
parce que la cocaïne c'est vous l'avez
signalé dans les ports de nord de
l'Europe une catastrophe hein ce qui
nous importe nous en prenant des mesures
c'est de à la fois de lutter contre la
le trafic de drogue mais d'éviter
par-dessus tout que la corruption rentre
dans ce pays parce que les les les les
narcos en Europe du Nord c'est une balle
dans la tête ou une enveloppe de billet
hein et donc il y a des cas de
corruption et on a la chance d'avoir un
pays qui n'est pas corrompu et dans
lequel pourrait justement rentrer la
corruption par ce biais-là alors les
portes du nord de l'Europe prennent des
dispositions certes mais fort
heureusement pour nous nous n'en sommes
pas au même niveau de difficulté que que
même en vert en octobre ils ont saisi 35
tonnes de cocaïne ils ont saisi hein ce
qui veut dire qu'il en est passé on
n'est pas sur ces niveaux-là hein dans
nos ports dans nos ports français fort
heureusement pour nous mais il faut que
nous réhaussions notre dispositif
justement pour ne pas être le maillon
faible par rapport à l'effort qu'il font
alors vous avez raison de dire que je je
parle des grands ports maritimes je ne
parle pas des ports décentralisés ni des
ports de plaisance hein parce que on
trouve également de la drogue dans les
navires de plaisance alors c'est pas les
tonnages qu'on peut qu'on peut
trouver mais on peut trouver 500 kg 700
kg voire une tonne euh le kilo de de
cocaïne quand il arrive ici mais je
pense que les les
précédent personne entendu ont dû le
dire il est à plus de 30000 € hein donc
500 kg c'est quand même ça vous fait un
petit peu d'argent hein il sort des
lieux de production à 1000 dollarsin
donc vous voyez le l'argent monstrueux
que que ça représente et donc ça vaut le
coup quelques centaines de kilos donc de
toute façon on sait qu'on a devant nous
cette difficulté sur les petits ports et
sur la navigation de plaisance hein il
va falloir que nous renforcions les
dispositifs étatiques dans le contrôle
de la plaisance parce qu'aujourd'hui la
plaisance est conçue comme un système
extrêmement ouvert alors il existe
heureusement en matière de plaisance et
c'est un dispositif dont j'aimerais bien
m'inspirer mais il faudrait qu'à ce
moment-là modifier la loi aux Antilles
il y a un dispositif d'idocairence
c'est-à-dire que que les gens qui font
de la plaisance parce que c'est c'est
lié au système antillaise ça se passe
comme ça dans tout la zone
antillaise euh on est obligé de déclarer
son lieu de destination ou son lieu de
provenance hein donc ça permet d'avoir
un peu cette visibilité sur ce qui se
passe en matière de plaisance mais pas
du tout quand les navires arrivent en
Europe hein donc on sait qu'on a devant
nous un changement de nature des
contrôles à faire sur tout le dispositif
maritime hein ça n'est que le début au
travers des grands ports et on devra
demain s'intéresser à tout ça euh et
d'ailleurs d'une façon général euh il va
falloir mettre malheureusement des
contrôles le dispositif aérien pour
essayer de comparer hein ce qui est
peut-être pas comparable mais on voit
que nos nos nos amis dans le domaine
aérien et je suis un ancien directeur
général d' l'aviation civile rentrer sur
un aérodrome c'est extrêmement compliqué
rentrer dans un port c'est pas forcément
très très comp
compliqué il y a tout le dispositif PNR
en matière
aérien en matière aérienne ça n'existe
pas en matière de circulation maritime
donc on voit bien que voilà il y a il y
a y a il y a bien des choses à faire
alors les relations avec le secteur
privé moi je coordonne l'effort de de de
de lutte contre la drogue dans les ports
mais la relation avec le monde privé il
est fait par le ministère des Transports
mais par exemple pour installer les
scanners de la la discussion que nous
avons en ce
moment avec les autorités portuaires il
faut bien évidemment trouver des
terrains euh qui soit au plus près du
lieu de déchargement des containerses
donc ça se fait avec tous les opérateurs
portuaires pour trouver le terrain qui
va bien aménager au plus près des
containers de manière à pas immobiliser
les containers parce que ce qui compte
dans l'efficacité portuaire c'est la
rapidité de déchargement ou de
chargement à l'inverse donc il faut pas
qu'on soit soit un obstacle à la
compétitivité de nos nos ports donc il
faut qu'on ait le terrain qui va bien
dans lequel on nmobilise pas trop
longtemps le scanner qu'on a demandé à
examiner qui ressorte assez rapidement
mais qui soit sécurisé et cetera bon
faut pas oublier que cette relation avec
le secteur privé elle passe également
par une demande qui a été faite à tous
les opérateurs portuaires de durcir leur
dispositif informatique parce que c'est
bien c'est bien beau de le faire de
façon matérielle en isolant un certain
nombre de containers
mais il faut que derrière leur
dispositif
informatique résiste aussi à des à des
pénétration de manière à ce que les
trafiquants n'aillent pas se servir
directement en détournant les systèmes
informatiques donc vous voyez c'est pas
uniquement mat on a des exemples où ça
s'est produit ù des dispositifs
informatiques portuaires ont été haqués
par des réseaux oui oui il il y a des
exemples oui il y a des enquêtes qui ont
été identifié qui ensuite ont été
poursuivis il y a des enquêtes
judiciaires en cours hein elles sont en
cours sur effectivement des suspicionss
puisque les enquêtes sont en cours
d'action de cette nature bah si vous
voulez tous les containers sont sont
sont immatriculés et donc ils sont dans
le dispositif portuaire et
l'autorisation de les c'est est donnée
par par informatique donc si vous
rentrez dans le système que vous
identifiez votre que vous savez où est
votre container c'est moins compliqué
qu'aller le chercher sans autorisation
sur le port c'est c'est le dispositif
parfait euh parce que alleer le chercher
sur le port quand vous n'y avez n'avez
pas le droit vous oblige à corrompre
éventuellement la chaîne qui permet
d'accès d'aller accès d'aller accéder au
container voire même ce qu'on observe
c'est de mettre des gens dans les
containers puisque une des méthodes des
des trafiquants c'est que vous avez des
gens qui s'installent dans le containire
avec la drogue et qui font le passage
transatlantique et qui quand il sont
arrivés ouvrent le container de
l'intérieur et sortent ainsi la
marchandise toujours avec des complices
quand c'est trop compliqué euh de le
faire en zone portuaire ils le font à
l'extérieur lorsque le container est
sorti à l'extérieur de la zone portoire
donc ça s'arrête jamais mais c'est vrai
qu'aller directement à l'essentiel en
prenant le contrôle du dispositif
informatique et est absolument et très
très efficace voilà pour essayer de vous
répondre madame la sénatrice sur les les
petits ports on a bien conscience qu'on
en est qu'au début des efforts qu'on
qu'on doit fournir et que de toute façon
on sera confronté à une variété du
trafic qui est extrêmement enfin qui est
assez spectaculaire et on sait que là on
parle des navires pilotés mais demain
enfin c'est pas demain à vrai dire ça
commence à arriver on aura les passages
par drone maritime hein pas pas
forcément des drones volants hein parce
que là il l'autonomie mais des drones
transatlantiques qui vont bien
évidemment arriver
hein
catherinene oui Monsieur le Secrétaire
général merci vous avez parler de
l'innovation entre guillemets de la
clairance aux Entilles elle est très
récente ça doit dater d'à peine 6 mois
ça a pris un temps fou à se mettre en
place et c'est ce sont des entreprises
privées pour la plupart qui réalisent
cette cl
alors qu'en face beaucoup de
plaésanciers martiniqu vont à cette luci
la Clairence elle est extrêmement
drastique à cette luci et pourtant on
sait qu'il y a un gros trafic qui vient
de cette île aussi bien en matière de
drogue qu'en matière d'arme au bout de
ces quelques mois est-ce que vous avez
déjà des bilan est-ce que ça fonctionne
bien est-ce que les gens s'y soumettent
parce que bon on doit jouer avec les
heures d'ouverture et de fermeture des
commerces afférant à cette démarche et
j'ai l'impression
en tout cas pour observer moi en étant
souvent invité par des plaisanciers que
il y en a pas mal qui zappent cette
cette formalité
oui mais je je pense madame la sénatrice
que que certains zappent mais si vous
voulez l'essentiel était comme vous le
dites de la mettre en place en fait elle
existait un peu en pratique mais elle
était pas
systématisée parce qu'on a eu quelques
petites difficultés à trouver le biais
juridique pour que le préfet prenne son
arrêté préfector
établissant la dite Clairence voilà
derrière ça la douane est en train de de
de mettre la main à l'élaboration d'un
fichier qui nécessitera d'être déclaré
de passer à l'acnil donc qui nous qui
nous permettra aussi d'avoir une
traçabilité du dispositif que pour le
moment nous n'avons pas donc c'est un
processus qui qui est assez long et
assez lent mais nous sommes un pays de
droit et il faut malheureusement passer
par un certain nombre d'étape lorsqu'il
y a qu je devrais pas dire
malheureusement mais par rapport aux
nécessités du moment nous avons toutes
ces étapes à à franchir j'espère que
dans un deuxième temps lorsque nous
aurons consolidé avec les fichiers on
pourra progressivement resserrer le
dispositif mais si je le citais tout à
l'heure c'est que moi je je le je le
cite par rapport à la métropole comme
l'exemple de ce qu'il faudrait faire en
métropole de ce qu'il faudra faire dans
un deuxième temps là par contre faudra
sans doute modifier la loi hein pour y
arriver parce que nous n'avons pas les
outils juridiques en métropole pour le
faire mais c'est c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose qui me paraît tout à fait
pertinent et tout à fait remarquable
alors vous avez raison faut pas que dans
le dans dans la zone antillaise nous
nous fion décrocher par les pratiques
des autres pays parce que là il y a des
risques de report hein même si aux
Antill vous le savez ça n'est pas
uniquement un problème de drogue il y a
aussi tous les problèmes de trafic
d'armes hein qui sont particulièrement
sensible dans cette zone-l euh mais
c'est
c'est c'est ça préfigure ce que nous
devons faire je pense à mon avis hein en
matière de de de plaisance sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire hein mais
voyez derrière derrière c'est une autre
approche de ce qui'est la plaisance le
le problème maritime c'est que enfin le
problème le le monde maritime était
jusqu'à présent un monde de de liberté
c'est-à-dire dans
lequel la mer était un espace ouvert
assez peu réglementé dans lequel il y
avait des usages organisés par les
traités internationaux notamment par
exemple lorsque il y avait des naufrages
d'aller secourir les gens hein ça tout
ça mais en dehors de ces règles très
générales
euh c'est quand même assez imprécis donc
il faut qu'on qu'on construise notre
droit en fonction des nouvelles menaces
et elles arrivent à toute vitesse elles
modifient les choses et ell pose parfois
des des des des questions assez
compliqué par exemple quand des bateaux
des
ONG secourent en
Méditerrané des
migrants qui sont pas dans un dispositif
euh où leur embarcation
coule qu'est-ce que c'est exactement en
droit comme action
oui comment c'est un sauvetage oui mais
alors on voit bien que là c'est
l'approche qu'on a en fonction de ce
qu'on pense du sujet mais qu'est-ce que
c'est en matière de droit maritime moi
je me limite au droit maritime j'ai pas
d'autres c'est compliqué hein à
qualifier en droit maritime c'est voilà
et en permanence on est voilà vous avez
des route dans le Golf de Guinée par
exle il y a deux routes d'arrivée de la
cocaïne de routes maritimes qu'on
connaît la route des port d'Europe du
Nord on vient d'en parler et il y a la
route du Golfe de
Guinée ensuite quand la marchandise est
débarqué dans le Golfe de Guinée euh on
sait qu'il y a une route maritime de
cabotage qui arrive jusqu'au Maroc et
puis il y a une route terrestre qui
remonte également vers
vers l'Afrique du Nord et qui de toute
façon pour ce qui nous concerne arrivera
soit à Marseille soit à 7 pour euh la
sénatrice Carlotti
donc voilà donc où est-ce qu'on se
positionne pour être le plus efficace
alors la route terrestre maintenant
c'est plus un sujet pour être le plus
efficace hein puisqu'on n plus dans un
certain nombre de zones dans lesquelles
notre action militaire nous servait
aussi à lutter contre ce trafic hein
dont on sait qu'une partie passe par le
Sahel hein euh donc est-ce qu'on se
situe dans le cabotage mais on est dans
les eaux intérieures d'un certain nombre
de pays donc il faut avec eux avoir des
accords euh pour justement les aider
c'est aussi cette coopération en matière
d'action de l'État en mer dans tout le
golfe de Guinée qu'on essaie de mettre
en place avec tous ces tous ces pays
riverins du Golfe de Guinée et encore il
y a une dizaine de jours la marine
sénégalaise a saisi euh a saisi un gros
tonnage dans ses dans ses eau euh grâce
au travail conjoint qu'on a fait avec
elle hein
d'autres questions chez nos sénateurs
Olivier
Cadic merci oui vous avez cité les les
navires qui éteignent leur ais on
pourrait citer aussi certains bateaux de
pêche dans certains pays qui ont
l'habitude de faire ça quand ils
approchent de nos côtes
donc comme dans la cyber c'est en fait
c'est le point faible par là où passent
les gens qui veulent nous attaquer et
vous avez parlé du port d'enverse où il
y a eu beaucoup de saisie
effectivement mais on pense que ça c'est
un peu la conséquence du fait que
Rotterdam a sacrément durci ses
contrôles puisque ils se sont mis en
fait à contrôler scanner tous les
containers ce qui fait qu'un certain
nombre de containers sont partis se sont
reportés et pourquoi effectivement vous
avez eu
la je pense l'élégance de signaler queil
y a un lien entre la compétitivité et
puis la vitesse et puis le contrôle bah
si on contrôle il suffit de voir le
brexit maintenant depuis qu'on passe à
Calais bah les temps de contrôle B ça
met plus de temps pour traverser
donc donc c'est un vrai sujet pour la
compétitivité mais est-ce que vous
comment vous situeriez nos ports par
rapport justement aux autres port
européens en terme de de niveau de
protection de de contrôle et est-ce
qu'il ne doit pas y avoir une action
européenne dans ce cas-là parce que si
effectivement il y a des trous dans la
raquette de toute façon on contrôle à un
endroit mais ça va passer par un autre
port et donc le problème restera entier
pour pour le le trafic donc est-ce que
vous n'envisagez pas quelque chose au
niveau européen on parle du golf de
grinée de Guinée il se trouve que je
suis passé à cribi qui est donc au sud
de de Douala et un port nouveau port en
eau profonde et j'ai pu voir les
installations qui sont en cours avec un
port totalement digitalisé avec
l'objectif que 100 % des conteneurs vont
être scannés et est-ce qu'il y aurait
une interconnexion possible au niveau
informatique justement avec avec ces
endroits là pour automatiquement être
averti et en amont voir pouvoir repérer
les les containers avant même qu'ils
arrivent et donc
enfin parce qu'en fait ce problème cette
problématique vous avez raison de dire
que ce qu'il faut c'est voir le contrôle
aussi en amont il y a des ports qui ont
un niveau très faible au niveau du
passage il se trouve que au Brésil où
j'ai j'étais là il y a pas longtemps il
y a aussi cette cet enjeu pour eux par
exemple au port de Santos où ils ont
aussi cette volonté d'augmenter le
nombre de le niveau de de contrôle de
des containers est-ce que vous avez des
des notes en fonction des ports pour
vous alerter enfin qui ferait qu'il y
aurait plus de contrôle en fonction de
de la provenance des ports pour pouvoir
justement faire pression aussi sur sur
l'amont pour que on sache que si ça part
de ce port là il y a beaucoup plus de
chance d'être contrôlé tant qu'on
contrôlera pas à 100 %
merci ça se fait déjà monsieur le
sénateur c'est-à-dire que on sait que
statistiquement si on contrôle 2 % des
containers la totalité des containers on
contrôle dans le monde 10 % des
containerss venant d'Amérique du Sud
donc il y a dans tous les états
une une nécessité d'un d'unun meilleur
contrôle de des des containerss
provenant de cette zone là après euh il
faut arriver à identifier qu' viennent
bien de cette zone là parce que une
caractéristique des Antilles c'est de
servir de zone de rebond he donc la
marchandise est remise dans d'autres
endroits d'autres containers et cetera
donc les trafiquants savent très bien
camoufler enfin essayer de camoufler les
origines bon sur les dispositifs de
contrôle on a des coordinations avec les
pays d'Europe du Nord sans que ça soit
une décision européenne sur les inform
formtion les contrôles et
cetera je pense qu'on a tous les moyens
juridiques pour faire tout ça une
initiative communautaire pourquoi pas
mais faudrait pas qu'elle se traduise
par des des transpositions compliquées
qui retardent d'autant plus enfin
on le contrôle on n pas de besoin
particulier d'outils juridiques
supplémentaires on les a simplement
après il faut mettre en place les
dispositifs avec la contradiction que
vous releviez qui est
on oscile entre rapidité et contrôle en
permanence
quoi et c'est compliqué dans le domaine
portuire d'expliquer aux différents
opérateurs y compris d'ailleurs au
docker que d'un seul coup on vient
contrôler de
l'extérieur que que que des gens qui
avaient l'habitude de rentrer dans
certaines zones d'un seul coup on va
leur dire ah bah attendez on va vous
cribler avant donc on on va heurter des
habitudes des pratiques mais j'observe
quand même que du côté des dockers qui
était quand même très attentif à tout ça
depuis euh ce qui s'est passé au Havre
où il y a eu des meurtres de docker
euh ils sont quand même assez demandeur
aussi d'une sécurité parce que encore
une fois avec la cocaïne on n' pas
affaire au même type de trafiquant on a
affaire à des gens d'une extrême
violence et qui qui n'hésite pas euh à
menacer les familles euh et
éventuellement à tuer des gens hein
c'est les narcotrafiquants rentrent dans
une autre dimension alors
euh de toute façon si vous me permettez
cette mauvaise comparaison ça sera
toujours la course entre les les
gendarmes et les voleur on sait très
bien qu'à chaque fois qu'on réhaussera
nos dispositifs il se passera d'autres
choses chez les trafiquants je vous
évoquis tout à l'heure que l'imagination
et et est sans fin chez chez les
trafiquants enfin dans dans les maritime
enfin dans les interpellations maritimes
qu'on fait on trouve quand même des
choses assez extravagantes entre les
gens dans des contéire les caissons
soudés sous les caisses avec de la
[Musique]
drogue c'est c'est quand même ça prouve
et la cocaïne a cette particularité
aussi d'être assez camouflable dans des
liquides ou dans des
pâtes vous en trouvez quelquefois dans
dans dans l'armature même du navire donc
donc faut démonter le bateau pour parce
qu'elle a été mélangée à des panneaux de
bois à des
vêtements donc faut faut faut bien avoir
conscience de de ce que c'est quoiin et
donc on sait très bien que si on arrive
à reéhausser le dispositif container on
limitera parce que c'est là où passent
les gros
tonnages les plusieurs quand on trouve 4
tonnes de cocaïne en principe c'est pas
sur sur une personne mais de toute façon
on va être confronté après à des des
d'autres choses d'autres choses il y a
quand même il y a quand même des
semisubmersibles il y a quand même enfin
c'est des gens qui ont énormément
d'argent énormément de moyens et qui de
toute façon vont servir des évolutions
technologiques voilà donc bon la Guinée
le Golfe de
Guinée la coopération dans le Golfe de
Guinée est moins facile qu'elle n'était
il y a il y a quelques années hein euh
il y a aussi de gros investissements qui
sont fait dans des dans des ports
euh avec semble-t-il des capitaux
étrangers
euh et qui du coup effectivement change
un peu la la la
physionomie de de cette zone là dans
laquelle il faut montrer notre
efficacité au au aux gens qui sont en
charge de l'action de l'État en mer
notre efficacité et montrer que c'est
pas simplement un retour de pratique
ancienne dont ils ne veulent plus mais
qu'on est véritablement dans la
coopération donc on essaie de montrer
cette efficacité mais c'est nettement
plus difficile qu'avant
oui Étienne blanc oui
et vous pouvez nous préciser si
aujourd'hui la France est dotée de drone
de dispositif de drone pour surveiller
son espace
maritime
oui bah de toute façon on a le
dispositif Marine nationale la Marine
nationale a des drones embarqués donc la
surveillance passe évidemment par des
drones
euh j'imagine que vous pensez plutôt au
drones qui sont qui son qui partent de
la terre et en direction de la mer là on
en a quelques-uns oui bien évidemment
euh où on se sert de
drones de de de gros drones par exemple
aux Antilles hein on a on a un
dispositif de drone qui permet de
surveiller des zones plus vastes mais
c'est à l'évidence qu'il faut faire
alors on a des radars quand même hein on
a aussi des radars qui permettent de de
surveiller le trafic maritime notamment
aux Antilles on a un gros projet de de
de de de d'installation de radar de
modernisation de nos systèmes de radar
on en a aussi en métropole c'est
d'ailleurs
un des
difficultés sur le dispositif éolien en
mer il va falloir reporter les radars
au-delà des éoliennes en mer pour voir
toujours le plus loin possible mais il
est clair que les drones les drones de
surveillance sont sont sont l'avenir
parce qu'il nous permettent d'éviter
d'immobiliser un moyen nautique he et de
voir beaucoup beaucoup plus loin je vais
vous donner un autre exemple sur lequel
on aurait besoin de drone mais pour
simplement illustrer le propos vous
savez comme aussi bien que moi que
Mayotte est soumis à à une forte
pression migratoire qui vient Comor mais
qui vient également de Madagascar voir
de de l'Afrique des grands lacs et donc
il faudrait que nous voyons hein
toujours en zone internationale il
s'agit pas d'aller voir sur ce qui
relève des des États concernés par
exemple voir ce qui se passe entre
Madagascar et les côtes africaines
seraient dans un certain nombre de cas
extrêmement utile et donc ça on ne fera
que par drone donc oui monsieur le
rapporteur nous avons déjà la Marine
nationale a déjà des drones euh oui il
en existe il y a des annes
administration qui on des drones hein
euh euh les douanes ont des drones les
affaires maritimes on utilisent des
drones sont pas forcément leurs drones
mais qui sont des drones loués ou dans
le cadre d'accords internationaux et
puis oui il nous en faut de de de plus
en plus hein ça ça ça paraît assez clair
faut pas oublier qu'en métropole he on a
aussi quand même le le dispositif
sémaphorique hein qui fait que comme
vous le savez euh la Marine nationale
dans le cadre dans le cadre de de de
d'une posture militaire de surveillance
sert également dans à surveiller le
trafic
maritime à la fois pour le surveiller
pour des raisons de police mais aussi
pour le surveiller pour des raisons de
de sécurité vous savez que le le rail
manche mer du Nord est un endroit
extrêmement sensible on a toujours son
prédisposé des des des moyens assez
lourd pour éviter les catastrophes
maritimes hein donc on a par ce biaisl
là un dispositif de surveillance on
essaie de mailler les
informations
mais même quand on maille les
information au plus près on n'est jamais
à l'abri de de de surprise par exemple
il y a y a des navires qui d'un seul
coup
ancrent malheureusement par malchance
juste à proximité des câbles et en et
quelquefois le navire dérive un peu et
arrache les câbles c'est c'est c'est ils
sont très très embêtés comme ils parlent
pas forcément français et un mauvais
anglais on arrive à s'entendre avec eux
mais il faut de temps en temps les aider
parce que ils ont un peu de
mal sur le le point de la corruption que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure qui est
un des sujets qui revient dans nombre de
nos auditions est-ce que vous avez des
craintes particulières des dispositifs
particuliers à développer au sein de de
vos propres services que c'est quelque
chose qui est prévalent déjà qui est
émergent qui est très ponctuel comment
comment vous identifier ce risque
là ah bah la corruption est un est plus
qu'un risque puisqu'on sait que au
Pays-Bas et en Belgique c'est un modus
opérandi extrêmement efficace et que les
gens qui refusent de se faire corrompre
sont menacés leur famillees le sont et
cetera et cetera donc on connaît cette
réalité hein d'ailleurs la presse s'en
fait écho tout ça est en est
parfaitement connu donc ce que ce que
nous voulons faire c'est assez simple
hein c'est de mettre nos agents à l'abri
de ce genre de menace pour être à l'abri
de ce genre de menace il faut que le
dispositif soit en permanence sous
surveillance par exemple j'ai une caméra
ici je peux toujours dire à la personne
qui souhaite me corrompre écoutez
j'aimerais bien
mais c'est pas possible donc c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
déploie un dispositif qui fasse que
l'agent qui soit docker qui soit
fonctionnaire militaire sera toujours en
mesure s'il le souhaite de trouver la
capacité de résister à ça donc il faut
vraiment mailler complètement le
dispositif pour qu'il a une traçabilité
de toutes personnes sur les pororts et
pour permettre à nos à nos agents de de
de résister enfin après il y a il y a
toujours des êtres faibles et qui se
laisseront corrompre mais on sait
comment finit ce type de corruption elle
finit assez mal et encore une fois
l'hypothèse des que les
narcotrafiquants arrivent à par ce BIA à
ébranler nos nos fondements républicains
me paraît une hypothèse assez sérieuse
hein et encore une fois la la la le moi
je suis toujours navré par les gens qui
prennent de la drogue et en particulier
ceux qui prennent de la cocaïne il
pensent que toujours que c'est leur
sujet personnel mais c'est les
fondements de cette nation qu's
ébranlent hein ils le vivent comme un
acte individuel mais c'est
collectivement qu'il nous mettent dans
une situation extrêmement
difficile y a-t-il chez les collègues de
le membres de la commission d'autres
questions Mons le
rapporteur je crois qu'il nous reste à
vous remercier chaleureusement pour
votre présence et les informations
utiles que vous nous avez donné merci
beaucoup puis on a un petit
questionnaire
écrit dont on serait heureux d'avoir les
communication ça sera transmis à la fin
la semaine merci beaucoup voilà
merci